let me ask you a question i mean this
this this transitions us into the
conversation we had yesterday right
uh and the conversation is about god
right now if you look at god the debate
for god is what let's look at the
debates for god there's how many
different camps we've got oh so many
there is the camp of people who believe
there is a god and within that camp
there's how many religions a ton too
many pick and choose but there's a ton
right
you know
judaism
christianity lds jehovah muslim
you know if you want to put scientology
christian catholicism buddhism buddhism
taoism
sikhs there's a lot right but they
believe there is a creator there's a god
the other camp is what
well agnostic they believe there is a
god they just don't know
not convinced not convinced and then you
have the atheists that flatta believes
what
there's not a god yeah the community for
atheists believe it or not is very small
it's only like four million people it's
not a big number worldwide it's not a
big number if you look at the can you
kind of pull up what percentage of the
world
total uh atheist population worldwide i
think i think it's a
it's not a big number it's a small
number so we got three different camps
okay i thought it would be larger than
that yeah me too
uss3 million worldwide is what 450 to
500 million uh there are 450 atheists
and agnostic wait a minute because
that's not that's not the same thing so
atheists and agnostic i don't put them
in the same camp
agnostic is a completely different uh
understanding than atheists agnostic
just to be clear i think atheism is you
basically say there is nothing agnostic
is you're not sure if there is or there
isn't you just don't know yeah that's
you don't know which is fine so that's
not like a no matter what there's not a
god okay so it's okay we'll figure it
out later okay
so now today with everything that's
going on okay
uh do we have more people believing in
god today or fewer people believing in
god today
i would guess fewer
percentage-wise i don't know because not
population percentage i think well it
depends when you say god like when
people start using the term like
celestial creator or a universal energy
i feel like they're still believing in
god they're believing in something like
when you talked about people praying you
know how how praying centers you uh and
that people should pray more i'm like
man i feel like people talk about prayer
now more than when i was a kid they just
rebranded it as uh as uh manifesting
manifest right manifesting the speaker
yeah and it's like that because there's
someone's praying that's praying they're
scared is that not praying yeah they use
the word meditation yeah i meditate it's
what i do and rather than saying prayer
they use meditation it's a more
politically correct one or affirmations
as well meditation is slightly different
than affirmation affirmation is
restating the same thing over and over
and over again until you believe it
meditation is more you're sitting there
you're praying you're thinking about a
topic what do you do pat no i listen i
gotta tell you i mean for me
uh prayer is is uh is magical you know
tom's in a hospital tom's in the
hospital with pneumonia and cobit right
thomas tom zenner yeah
tom ellsworth he's in the hospital
pneumonia he was in icu for the last
couple of days
the biz dog the best dog so what yes
he's uh he's there now man
today's his best day okay today's his
best day okay
i hope you're listening we're thinking
of you man
yeah everybody misses me
is he gonna is there any chance he's
gonna be here for the vault we don't
know we're gonna see what's gonna happen
the only thing we're thinking about is
his health right
so prayer okay prayer to me but i think
about
like we we went to the question and said
okay what country would you rather have
raise your kids in would you rather live
in a country where the top believes in
certain values and principle and there
being a god or the top believes in there
is no god they're atheist they're
agnostic like ah you know whatever we
don't need to follow certain guys
judeo-christian values you prefer that
values and principles yeah well that's
what we grew up with
but let's take that out
let's take that out
and let's say we don't have that what
does that world look like
let's take that let's take it out and
say listen i think it's like you know i
used to go to school we used to pray you
don't do that anymore you used to go to
school you used to stand up to
you know the flag you don't do that it's
offensive we used to go and do certain
rituals right i remember one time i'm at
uh
the owner of publix storage's house in
l.a in malibu beautiful home and dennis
prager got up and he says what makes a
great country is great and what makes
religions great is rituals and he's a
jew and you know jews have a lot of
symbolism a lot of symbolism and rituals
right we used to pray we don't do that
anymore so imagine like you're standing
up and praying to a flag or standing up
and saluting to a flag or looking up to
a flag what does that do to a
six-year-old
what does it do to an eight-year-old
what does it do to a ten-year-old what
does it do when you pray
do you really believe in prayer at that
time do you sit there and say oh my gosh
prayer works or do you sit there and say
what if this works i don't know if this
works what does a kid think about but at
least you're thinking right well maybe
someone's got my back maybe someone's
watching me is it good to think a
creator is watching us have we gotten
away from that why don't we want a
creator to watch us is it because we
don't like accountability is it because
we want to be kind of a uh rebels and
not have anybody hold this account what
is it like what or is it because we had
a bad experience with a pastor with a
preacher with a priest something
happened like dude i don't believe in
any churches that's what happened with
me i was i was an atheist for 25 years
but the more and more you see the world
being a little bit out of whack the more
and more you question you know what i
don't know
maybe we need a little bit more
faith today not faith maybe we need a
little bit more prayer today maybe we
need somebody to just get up and say you
know what america times are a little bit
weird i think we got to pray today we
have somebody that just sits there like
you know like flat out a person gets up
there and prays for the entire country
today what if that happened how would
the world react how would america react
maybe the man upstairs if there is a man
upstairs is not happy
maybe imagine if a father did so much
for his kid and his kids are so spoiled
how would that father react
how would the father react with the
father sit there yesterday i was doing a
mentoring call on the elite webinar one
of the guys a guy kid named george liked
him and i said so tell me george says
well let me tell you now i think of
myself as one of these bill gates type
of guys i'm very cold nothing offends me
i don't get upset like he's talking in a
big game he's 23 years old i said so
really what kind of business do you run
he said i don't run a business i work
for my father my father you know he
doesn't know what he's doing i said your
dad doesn't know what he's doing no he
really doesn't know what he's done so
what is your dad he has a bunch of
hotels in greece and he's got a big
portfolio of real estate of 100 some
million dollars but i do it at all for
them i said really you managed to yeah
and we got all these seven other ceos
that are watching us that would do 20
100 million a year in business i said so
tell me uh who needs who more do you
need your dad or does he need you more
oh no question my dad can't survive
without me i'm like oh really he said
yeah so what are you going to do he said
well next year i'm going to go away from
my dad and do it on my own i said
fantastic what's your game plan he's
going to give me a few million dollars
to get started
i'm like everybody starts cracking i'm
like did you just hear yourself so my
dad did for me it was fine yeah so
so maybe if there is a creator just
maybe this creator if there is and he
plays the role of a father maybe he's a
little disappointed with all the stuff
that we have 100
maybe i don't know gerard what are your
thoughts uh
ah it's a long conversation um
i tell you man i am a man of faith i
believe in a creator i believe in a
universe i have a weird belief that we
are all uh connected of the same energy
i think science has kind of proven that
matter cannot be created or destroyed
we're all stardust we're all
interconnected and what i said yesterday
is that i believe in a collective
consciousness i believe there's this
thing called noetic science that kind of
studies this but there's this there's a
reason why home field advantage works
their collective consciousness is a real
thing there's a reason why prayer groups
seem to actually have effect right
so i think our collective consciousness
is off right now i think there's
something there there is sand in the
microchip i personally don't have much
like or use for religion i think faith
is of god religion is a man and i think
religion has been a tool used
for authorities
and
not unlike government in this regard i
feel like it is a thing for uh people
that are addicted to power to use to try
to take power and control over their
fellow man let me jump in on that if you
don't mind yeah because this came up
on my app this morning and i love what
you just said it says from ephesians 6
it says for our wrestling and not
against flesh and blood but against the
principalities against the powers
against the world rulers of this
darkness against the spiritual hosts of
wickedness in the heavenly places
so you know what that basically means is
that we're going through a lot of
craziness right now in this world
and that uh we need to be guarded
extremely guarded we and therefore we
need to come together no matter if you
believe in god or whatever we need to
come together and pat you brought up a
great
story about your son
you know praying you know showing prayer
and stuff like that at the end of the
day whether you believe in prayer or not
it's just positivity
we need to come together in some way and
understand that
something's wrong and in order to get
right we got to get right with ourselves
and we need to really have better
conversations when you say you know i
hear people say love thy neighbor this
that you're just saying it you're not
doing it
we're living in a world of just words
words words no actions no real honesty
hypocrisy is at an all-time high with
our leaders and all that stuff we have
no guts to even call out and then when
we do call out these so-called rulers
leaders we get canceled we get thrown to
the side and then when they come the
pendulum shifts
like we were talking about earlier like
you know you have the left doing all
this blah blah blah blah and then now
this whole biting thing now people from
the right are like point c cc it's like
but that doesn't work either yeah if we
could just say you know what man
hell yeah you messed up
but
i'm going to show you some grace
because there's a bigger goal here and
the goal is this
peace and we're on righteousness stuff
like that
yeah i don't know i think uh um
you know obviously where you are and
where you are you know with ephesians
you just read right there what is prayer
think about what prayer is prayer is
what you don't pray and say god i would
love it if you gave me a lamborghini
tomorrow and i would love if we get a
ferrari and if i get a hundred thousand
dollar check i will be more christian
next week and if you give me that
ferragamo shoes with the nice stefano
richie suit
i'm gonna go to church you're coming for
joel osteen hardy so yeah i'm going
after joel osteen
but you know what prayer is prayer is
prayer forces you to think about other
people
prayer is you know what i'm praying for
gerard you know he's going through a
certain phase right now probably gerard
told me something about his mom his dad
his brother or sister i'm gonna pray for
him and he looked like he was going
through some time right now i'm gonna
pray for adam you know hey you know he's
going through this i'm gonna pray for
tom
the part about prayer is makes you think
about others
it meditation is more you most of the
time
prayer is out
you're praying for someone else so what
would happen if we're coming from that
mindset you're thinking about other
people look for me all i know is you
give me a great
organization you give me a great family
that keeps winning you're gonna find
strong values and principles there and
the moment values and principles goes
away
havoc's about to take place okay now the
the the part about the the faith that we
didn't get into yesterday is
how many people you know that use the
bible as a weapon how many people do you
know that use
the the scripture as weapons i think
history is is chock full of i don't
disagree yeah yeah muslims may say a lot
of people use the quran as a weapon 75
percent of them say this is a religion
of what peace peace right hey you know
there's extremists but that's not us
you know guns let's talk about guns has
gone a good invention to the world i
think they think it's one of the
greatest inventions ever who did it help
the most men or women
women by far
what give me the split ten to one twenty
to one five to one i mean i mean we
talked about this you know
in podcast past but i mean like
literally this is the first time in the
history of our species yeah that not
being big strong and violent is the
the the marker of success and that the
the gun has equaled the playing field
for smaller people more intelligent
people even if people are able to
no longer just just bully their way into
success you can't get you know in a ship
with 16 other norsemen and go you know
across the english channel and take over
an entire time in a way yeah so i mean
again we talked about lebron james and i
call him the repentant rich i'm like
never in the history of man
could somebody that was born in that
status of life in akron ohio become a
billionaire he would have had to kill or
been responsible for organizing an army
that killed millions of people hundreds
of thousands of people in order to go
from poverty to a literal prince a king
like that so you know the fact that he's
a billionaire by playing ball and hole
and the fact that he can go and be on tv
every day where everybody knows where he
is and they know that he has all this
money and everything like that and he
doesn't have to worry about his family
being at home or his stuff being at home
he doesn't go to sleep every night
wondering if oh my god there's going to
be marauders coming to take everything
that i've earned in the middle of the
night he has
indirectly guns to thank for that yeah
so
let me let me jump in for a sec so
there's two
we started this conversation with
basically saying look we're a little off
track here right now you know we kind of
got to get
our central nervous system of our
consciousness together
but at the same time like what you're
saying i think this is the best that
humans have ever lived ever ever it's
quantified so exactly so you know like
charles dickens it was the best of times
it's the worst of times it's so easy to
point out all the bad stuff all this guy
on mushrooms like it's crazy
isis al-qaeda whatever whatever how many
people have been lifted out of poverty
how many people
over the last 50 years how many people
have clean drinking water now how many
people how many babies aren't dying
because polio isn't killing them the
second they're born it's so easy to just
jump on and pile on the bad the negative
things are bad which some in some cases
they are
but a lot of things are good man well a
lot of things are good i think the the
term is gratitude
and i think uh a lot of us have to
live in that moment a little bit more
right like instead of just complaining
and whining and touching and moaning we
have to be in more gratitude and like
you said i mean we are living in some
very strange times but at the same time
i mean look we're able to have this
podcast connect with people you know
we'll be changing you know hopefully
someone's perspective life whatever in
just us having this uh conversation yeah
you know but uh you know i feel very
fortunate in a lot of things i get to do
and that's because of you know evolution
so pat let me ask you this so you
brought up guns there so are you saying
that religion to you is analogous to a
gun
absolutely a lot of people here are
talking uh insane stuff like let me read
some what couple people said
uh uh uh
wars wars wars bible is a marco d pascal
bible is mostly fake and paul braz is
100 right uh you got another guy that's
talking about most paul baraz just gave
10 bucks and he said most people in
fairy tales
most most believe in fairy tales god and
religion sure seek
uh like it works lol
uh you know people talking trash about
god right and talking trash about bible
there's an interesting thing about the
bible i will say and i i love this stuff
by the way like i i i spend my weekends
reading up about this stuff i've told
you about my affinity for the historical
jesus whether i believe he's the son of
god or not the he's the greatest
activist of all time i am fascinated
with the life of of of yeshua i'm
fascinated by it and really the bible
and this is gonna piss some people off
but just try to have an open mind the
bible really all right that we know
today
is a treaty between
judaism monotheism and the roman empire
catholicism is a great uh it's it's an
understanding between the growing sex of
judaism jesus never wanted christianity
he was a jew through and through rabbi
and there was roman catholicism right
roman catholicism was the um what's the
word i'm looking for here the the uh
the compromise it was the compromise
between the dying old roman ways and the
new
roman as rome became eastern not western
so there's there's geopolitical like
it's fascinating politics behind this
stuff
if you can it and i'm not saying that
jesus isn't the son of god i'm not
saying that that it's not the word of
god that's not what i'm saying but if
you believe that religion is of man all
right and you know if you if you can
research the council of nicaea
understanding what this was from a
political standpoint is the most
fascinating times in human history we're
still talking about two thousand years
later it's the council of nicaea shaped
the world for the next you know 1200
1300 years it's it's a fascinating time
man so anyway i'm sorry but you asked
you asked a question though you asked
the question saying the gun comparison
to a bible right okay yeah so here's
here's how i see this uh anything can be
used as a weapon anything can be used as
a weapon right they
they say the moment you learn how to
persuade never go to the tipping point
of manipulate just to avoid you being
wrong at times
when you learn how to persuade
you're one
one move away from being a manipulator
just because you don't want because now
you know how to win arguments okay so if
the mission becomes about winning you
will tip into manipulating rather than
persuading i don't know if that makes
sense yeah it's kind of like what
lawyers are trying to do
so once you learn how to persuade you're
like listen this guy knows how to
persuade you know how to pursue you know
how to persuade i know how to persuade
but there's like you know what in this
argument he's beating me screw it i'm
going to manipulate because i don't want
to be yeah and by the way that's a
problem and that's a problem everybody
with power that knows how to persuade
has to deal with everybody happens in
marriage parenting right everything okay
let's set that part aside computer
that's a weapon
the bible can be used as a weapon this
is a weapon this right here is one of
the most powerful weapons in the world
today right so there's there's a couple
arguments me
i went through the phase of trying to
break everything down with the bible to
prove to everybody that the bible is
wrong
that was my outcome
you think the bible is right yes you
mean to tell me
that back in the days a woman's gonna
have a baby without and yeah we have to
believe it you want me to believe it
this was this the 23 year old kid that
would go to every pastor that he could
find and i would try to prove him wrong
that was this guy we are 20 to 23 years
old this is all i did for two and a half
years right you mean to tell me how to
believe that let me get this straight
what makes you think maybe she
hooked up with a guy that nobody knew
about and then boom next thing you know
she's got a baby to save her she has to
say well this is a god all this stuff
right okay
then people say well let's just say she
made that up
okay let's just say she made that up
what are the freaking chances
that she makes up the story
and the kid ends up becoming the biggest
influencer in the world
let's say so for me the skeptic is like
well
well there's chances what are the
chances 1 in 113 freaking billion okay
math of genius break that down for me
then i back up i'm like that was it
let me take a different angle well back
in the days people were so naive and a
person could come up with a great
communicator they can manipulate
everybody so you can use that as a
weapon to manipulate others okay great
it's still happening today but fine
let's just say the ivt level is lower
today
people were more knife back in the days
because they wanted to be controlled
every time i went to it finally got to
the following point here's what the
point is
are there some things you will never
know about your dad and your mom that
they will never tell you
are there stuff you're never going to
know about your parents like you know a
couple of the arguments or that part of
this part are there things that you will
never find out yes or no
if you spend the rest of your life
trying to figure out 100 accuracy of
who's right mom or dad are you ever
going to find that out yes or no you're
never going to find it out right okay
you can spend the rest of your life
trying to find out every single thing
about christianity jesus god everything
are you going to find that a hundred
percent truth of all of it 100 truth not
not 98
100 truth
so then that leaves us with what okay so
you got emotional you got logical let's
look at both sides okay
for me
on the logical side
um
do i want my kids to learn certain
values and principles to follow do i
feel more comfortable a country is being
built on a certain set of values and
principles
yes would i rather have my kids go to
church and not go to church yes would i
rather have my kids pray than not to
pray yes would i rather have my kids go
to an atheist school or jewish school
and i'm a christian myself i would try
to have would i rather have my kids be
held accountable to a certain level so
this whole thing about you're right
you're delusional you're this you're
that look you're talking to a guy that
spent the entire time trying to
mathematically prove everybody wrong in
the concept of bible oh noah you mean to
tell me this guy built a ship and two
animals on each side and came and all of
a sudden you mean come on bro that's a
freaking fictional story you believe
that i don't know
i don't know you mean to tell me that
such as i don't know what i'm trying to
tell you is i don't know what i am
telling you is if a person reads
proverbs they become a better human
being i don't know why
go read proverbs and see what happens to
you i don't know why i don't care what
you are just go start with proverbs
really see what happens afterwards i
think we need a little bit this is
coming from a guy that's a sinner this
is coming from a guy that's flawed this
is coming from a guy that's done a lot
of stupid in his life
but if i ever go more that side i make
better decisions i think today if
there's ever been a time the country
that was founded
on the right belief system who ends up
beating everyone in only 200 years
against empires that have been on for a
few thousand years maybe this country's
been blessed
and maybe we need to kind of go back a
little bit and say what was the
reasoning was it us
oh was there something else that was on
our side i don't know i would say this
and and this is where i i would agree
with the kind of uh judeo-christian
framework that you guys talked about
before right
um i don't think that the quote-unquote
atheist today
doesn't believe in a higher power i
think government is their higher power i
think that they believe in the system
the socialist system as their
judeo-christian framework i believe that
this especially this this nouveau
democratic socialist this isn't politics
to them this is religion to them and i
think part of the the argument that
we've had over the course of the last 10
years is you just talked about
intellectual versus emotional
politics is an intellectual conversation
there's there's ebb and there's flow
there's times where you need liberalism
and there's times where you need
concerns no question there's you know i
i always try to think in a binary system
you know you like to say two wings of
the same burn i think of the democrats
as the gas pedal and the republicans as
the break you need gas to move forward
you need a break or you're going to fall
off the cliff right so
i where i think we've gone awry in our
country in the last 10 years and i think
it's coming from the outside world
specifically hammering us uh is
this
kind of global communism this this
democratic socialism this is religion to
people for all the same ways i even said
this to you guys last night where you
guys are saying all right well you got
to think of your neighbor you need to
think of of someone bigger than yourself
you have to provide i'm like this is
what i hear from socialists all the time
this is this is social justice rhetoric
you know this is the stuff that they are
all the time saying the people at the
top have too much the people at the
bottom need to be taken care of you got
to think of somebody other than yourself
i'm like this is socialist rhetoric and
then you made a great point what is the
difference
there is one key difference and there's
one difference that separates everything
and that is force force
force force yep i have the choice you
know you don't have to pray i'm cool
with that right you don't have to give
money i'm cool with that it's a choice
how many times have i gone to church and
not given anything hundreds of times not
one oh my gosh what a sinner i'm telling
you the truth what do you want to tell
you i didn't give anything that day i
went to church i've gone to church so
many times
there's a great irish joke about that
you ever hear the irish catholic joke
but the point is i still walked out it
was a choice yeah did you hear that
so the uh old patty mcdougal old maddie
mcdougall goes in and he says forgive me
father it's uh i have sinned it's been
it's been seven days since my last
confession
what would you do patty well you know i
lusted over over me neighbor's wife
said well did you did you do anything no
but i thought about it i thought about
it a lot and i thought about it
constantly well you know thinking about
it is just as bad as doing it my son so
i'm going to need you to repent i repent
and then we're going to need penance
what do i need to do father seven hail
mary's and put ten quid in the box on
your way out to to show god you mean it
so he says this hail mary's and then he
goes to the to the donation box takes
the quit out and he holds it over the
top
and then puts it back in his pocket and
walks and the pastor goes out he goes
whoa whoa patty what what happened what
i i thought you were repenting he goes
well father i listened to your words and
i thought about it
and that's just as bad as doing it so i
figured okay
anyways by the way you know it's crazy
the the the for me
for years we followed the rhetoric which
is what which is
never talk politics never talk religion
never talk this kind of stuff and this
is what we talked about doing it all
today if you don't like it this ain't a
podcast for you i guarantee you but if
you like it smash that subscribe button
put a thumbs up to help us out with the
algorithms because we've got a few more
topics to go let me in the next 30
minutes let me give you one more thing
here we go folks everybody pay attention
turn off the computer tell your kids to
be quiet adam's got some thoughts for us
i just i'd be remiss if i didn't just
bring up i'm thinking you're going to
pray for all of us well it does involve
prayer okay
i think
you know prayer or affirmation or
meditation or thinking of others is
important
okay no doubt and i think
you know whether they say hey take a
second moment of silence that's great
but the whole
blanket we had an issue
thoughts and prayers hey can you get
your thoughts and prayers out there
today hey i i you know my dad's sick
really could use your thoughts and
prayers hey we just had another gun
tragedy thoughts and prayers
at the end of the day thoughts and
prayers don't do yes they don't
solve problems if they don't mean
anything well that's what i'm saying
like the old thoughts and prayers thing
i'm just so sick of the thoughts and
prayers thing are you sick of virtue
signaling you think of praying
the virtue's signaling but i'm not i'm
it's not being getting political it's
just the hey thoughts and prayers
oh we just had another 50 people guy
from a
gun violence
we really could use it
just like when i have friends from uh
the uk right so like i i you know travel
and you know i have a couple buddies out
in birmingham england right so they'll
say
why is it
that you guys always say have a nice day
he's like you guys don't mean that
one bit yeah have a nice day just have a
nice day it's just a saying so i totally
agree what you're saying i mean at the
end of the day we got to say what we
mean
and i know you want to move on papa that
the one thing that i did want to ask you
about this man is i mean you've talked
about this a lot i mean it's it's
interesting that you want uh
increased religion increased
accountability but you grew up in an
environment where you know religion gone
awry completely turned your world upside
down yeah but it was force
again it goes back to force
my kids everything is a choice
hey
you don't have to read today
it's the currency of the house but i
don't have to let you watch tv today but
you don't have to ever read in my house
but i don't have to ever let you watch
tv in our house it's a choice
hey you don't have to clean your bed
believe me buddy like i tell my son you
don't you don't need to who said you
need to clean your bed nobody said you
need to clean your bed but i don't need
to let you play ipad this weekend it's a
choice there's always a choice right i'm
still going to love you you're still
going to be my son i'm still going to
take care of you but i'm sorry video
games don't come if you don't do your
part i got to do my part life is tough i
got to do so the first part is the
problem in countries like iran because
you don't have the choice hey do you
want to cover your hair no problem do it
you don't no problem do it that was the
shaw's way you want to cover yourself go
forward
some people want to wear like you know
show everything cleavage and they want
to have the shirt hide and show their
belly buttons because it's pierced and
wear skimpy what do you call it uh
skirts guess what i'm sure you support
that you know i'm sure you're vietnamese
now somebody who's extremely attractive
doesn't want to show any of it she only
wants to show the show to her man so
every time you see her you're like she's
dropped it gorgeous but i have no clue
because she's always covered up that's
her choice great she wants to somebody
goes to the beach they wear a two-piece
and they got a thong on okay now that's
kind of weird but i like it let's just
say you like it some people go there
they don't want to wear that it's a
choice the force is the problem is when
the problem becomes a little bit
problematic for me so but to go back to
what you just said
and i've heard that a million times hey
david can you grab somebody to grab a
charger for my ipad please my ipad just
died if you guys got it i wouldn't mind
it here's what i will say about what you
just said okay
um
i
partially agree and i partially disagree
let me explain uh who have i
who have i known longer you or tom
uh tom okay
who gave ten thousand dollars to obama
and trump and uh said committed to i'm
gonna give ten thousand dollars for this
to happen your boy sauce who else here
gave that i don't know
but who here supports for that to become
a reality
everyone did mario give anything
not that mario aguilar no not him mario
didn't give anything yeah but does mario
want to support me doing the interview
to see uh bush and obama and trump be in
the same room of course i think that
there's levels to support some go above
and beyond some people all they can do
is say dude i'm just going to pray for
you i got nothing else to give you what
i'm going to do my thoughts and prayers
go for you right some say hey i'm not
only going to pray for you i'm going to
make a phone call to see if i can get a
guy to support you hey not only am i
going to pray for you i'm going to make
a phone call but i'm also going to come
out to your place to help you out
whatever you need i got you okay some
say thoughts and prayers some say call a
friend some come
and some go and give 50 000 or 10 000 so
there's levels i don't mind it as long
as the effort is to give something if
you want to give time to pray for me
that's a starter there's levels in life
you know hey if somebody works at a
company not everybody's going to be a
c-suite executive somebody may come here
and make sure the place is clean you're
contributing to society somebody wants
to come in here and edit fantastic
somebody wants a new cut great somebody
wants to grab i don't as long as we're
contributing the part about prayer is
the is the barrier to enter is just to
pray go for it there's no expectation
that's much better than a guy says screw
you i don't care what happens to this
guy so it's a way to at least get people
stopped i hear you on that there's
levels to this so but imagine you're
raising you're trying to you you pledged
five million dollars right yep and yeah
aaron zingerman called in he gave a half
a million i gave ten thousand yep this
person this person that's great imagine
if you were trying to raise a hundred
million dollars okay hypothetically
and all you got was a million people
giving you their thoughts and prayers
and my point is this it's just empty
it's just thoughts and prayers i think
how many people give you a thoughts and
prayers and literally don't think or
pray they just write that down and move
on with their life but guess who guess
who guess who's responsible for that
that's on everybody that's not that's
their character though that's their
character that's their character their
health response it only hurts one person
it's themselves you know my problem is
if there's actually something that needs
to get done whether
pick a pick a
pick health care pick gun violence pick
green new whatever it is
and then just thoughts and prayers it
doesn't get things done
i like choices if you don't want it sure
yeah and i leave it on you that's fine
i'm just saying it that i need something
more
if you're looking to raise money
i'm just saying if i'm looking to raise
money for a cause yeah and all you're
hitting me with is a million people give
me thoughts and prayers
buddy
i need someone i need some i need actual
money i need actual help i need you to
buy i know what you're saying i think
what's your story it's just an easy way
out it's a copy side of it it's fake
yeah there are people there are some
that will do it through fake looks just
for social yeah i fully get that so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you